zendaya is officially 25 years old i
just feel very lucky and her spider-man
co-star and rumored boyfriend tom
holland is among the first to sling some
birthday love her way
yeah i do my part where i can for sure
the british actor posted this sweet snap
to instagram on wednesday judging by
tom's spidey suit it looks like a
throwback of the stars in the hair and
makeup trailer while they were filming
the superhero flick
you ready yeah you're gonna love this
but it's tom's caption that has fans
gushing he writes quote my mj have the
happiest of birthdays give me a call
when you're up tom's birthday tribute
comes just weeks after the pair was
photographed showing off some pda in
july they were spotted kissing in a car
i am sweating and a source told et at
the time that the pair celebrated the
4th of july together with a getaway to
santa barbara
enjoying a weekend of casual dining
hanging poolside and even a round of
mini golf
i mean it's just hard to date in general
you know sometimes it's hard to you know
find people that you really click with
or really understand you and and add on
top of the fact that my lifestyle is
very different so i mean it's just tough
but i'm chilling now neither zendaya nor
tom has confirmed any relationship but
there has been plenty of romantic
speculation in the past
dating rumors first began in the summer
of 2017 amid the actors worldwide press
tour for spider-man homecoming have you
found that it's hard today in hollywood
so at such a young age of course it is i
mean it's hard today at any age i mean
it doesn't matter you know where you are
either i mean it's just hard to say in
general you know but zendaya shut down
the speculation at the time when she
told variety that tom is simply quote
one of her best friends and a great dude
and that august the euphoria star told
et she wasn't fazed by the romance
rumors i mean it happens all the time
and of course you know we we expected it
i mean it's it's um
it comes with the territory it comes
with the job so it was all good
fast forward to 2021 the pair teamed up
with their co-star jacob battalon to
help reveal the official title for the
webslinger's next movie spider-man no
way home i just don't understand why he
keeps doing this you don't understand i
feel like it's pretty obvious to spoil
things i don't spoil things you're
thinking one thing that i've actually
spoiled
the last movie title
this is slated to be the third and final
standalone mcu film for tom
and while we wait for an official
confirmation or maybe a red carpet
outing here's a little tom and zendaya
cuteness to hold you over fittingly
discussing zendaya's birthday in 2019.
they went to the harry potter studios
for my birthday it's very exciting
very upsetting because the harry potter
studios were directly outside the studio
where i was working it's not outside
it's literally
literally on the same level yeah so
while they were having so much fun i was
being beaten up by a hydro man in our
behind the scenes uh footage that we got
there's the most amazing footage of you
and it's spider-man taking a drink on
set yeah it's an interesting contraption
to say the least basically my eyes in my
mask they clip off they come off because
they're glass and and obviously the suit
is fabric and they need to clip in and
what i can do is i can take my left one
out and there's a little like
thing that i pull out and then i put a
um
a tube a squeezy tube down into my mouth
and then i can drink drink from a
from a bottle thanks so much i'm really
struggling
but what i found out now is that this
video of you doing that in new york and
this little kid just like remember the
store
oh yeah
in a store there's this little kid
behind him just watching him drink from
his eye like you're ruining what is
[Music]
happening you